[Musik]
also herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt's eine
torte die hat sich die er schon länger
mal gewünscht und zwar soll es eine
princes bodo tsunami torte werden
produktion amick habe ich hier in diesem
jahr schon mal gemacht das war ein
richtig großer trend nämlich eine torte
bei der man die backform oder die folie
hochzieht und dann kommt diese klausur
über die torte geschwommen ja das ganze
wollen wir jetzt mit der elsa probieren
und zwar dass die ein kleid bekommt und
dann soll das kleid sich so darüber
fließen in die provinz auf jeden fall
werde ich älter geflechten aber das
macht nichts denn gleich finden wenn der
chor im ofen ist das machen was leicht
damit sogar wieder schöne prinzessin
frisur bekommt ich werde jetzt hier
einen ganz einfachen kuchenbacken
rührkuchen und die torte ist auch
wirklich gar nicht so schwer ich zeige
euch wie ihr die schnell und einfach
packen können dafür nämlich 350 gramm
zucker etwas salz zitrone passte 150
milliliter buttermilch und
sonnenblumenöl und 300 gramm mehl oder
back mail oder nehmt so mehl dazu noch
ein bisschen backpulver genau falls ihr
fragt man benutzt wie gesagt kein balkon
vor dazu geben ansonsten findet ihr die
backpulver angabe einfach bei mir in der
es jetzt verrührt ihr die eier mit dem
zucker salz und mit zitrone passte ich
habe mir gedacht ich packte jetzt
einfach ein bisschen zitronengeschmack
nämlich mit rein ihr könnt auch ein
bisschen zitronen abrieb benutzen ich
habe mir einfach direkt die paste
dann können die zutaten verrühren für
etwa fünf bis zehn minuten in der zeit
werde ich schon mal die torten ringe
einstellen ich nehme ich einfach vier
kleine zwei berge ringe und zwei mini
trockne 12 cm und 10 ihr könnt aber auch
wenn ihr keine backformen habt könnt ihr
das ganze auf dem blech backen und
später einfach ausstechen das geht auch
als man braucht wirklich keine besondere
backform dafür
[Musik]
dann gebt ihr hier jetzt die beiden
flüssigkeiten dazu butter milch und öl
ihr könnt auch normale mails nehmen ihr
könnt auch eine limonade nehmen aber
durch eine limonade wird das ganze noch
süßer und ich glaube das machen wir
jetzt hier nicht aber normale milch geht
auch
und auch direkt das mehl mit dem
backpulver vermischen und sieben oder
vans backen möchte das nicht 7 und jetzt
nur noch ganz kurz ein ringen
und dann schön gleichmäßig aufteilen und
im vorgeheizten ofen backen
[Musik]
streicht die immer gern auch ein
bisschen noch hoch am rand und ich achte
jetzt einfach drauf dass ich den teig so
ein fülle dass die kleineren bisschen
höher gefüllt sind dann haben sie
nämlich ungefähr die gleiche backzeit
und dann passt es auch mit doofen
einstellung
[Musik]
jetzt sind die böden gebacken und
abgekühlt es kann direkt an die
buttercreme gehen wie gesagt wird dass
jetzt eine recht einfache torte deswegen
greife ich jetzt auf die buttercreme von
d kino zurück ihr könnt aber auch auf
einem kanal schauen da gibt es eine
deutsche buttercreme eine amerikanische
buttercreme italienisches wismar rang
buttercreme amerikanische gibt es
übrigens nach dieser nämlich zu süß hat
vielmehr ebenso an egal ich mache jetzt
die butter kreeb dafür brauche ich dann
250 milliliter wasser ein päckchen
butter creme und 300 gramm weiche butter
das geht jetzt relativ einfach denn
fährt einfach den wollt ihr inhalt erst
mal mit dem wasser
das sagen gerade so kurz vor dem
geburtstag hat man vielleicht auch mal
weniger zeit und bereitet noch viele
andere dinge vor und dann ganz ehrlich
fühlt euch nicht schlecht dabei einfach
mal eine zeitige buttercreme zu benutzen
ist so
da das wasser dazu
falls es eine torte wird für erwachsene
könnt ihr das wasser auch gerne mal
austauschen durch kaffee zum beispiel
dann habt ihr direkt eine kaffee
buttercreme
oder saft
das sieht jetzt ein bisschen aus wie
kleister ist es aber nicht darf aber
jetzt trotzdem hier ganz kurz an der
seite im business stehen das muss
nämlich jetzt 30 minuten ruhen und ich
kann die zeit nutzen und die köthen
herauslösen und schon mal durchschneiden
[Musik]
dankeschön torten assistenz
ripplinger und panik konditorei
schädlinge und jedes schöne konditorei
komitee das für alles
wir machen eine agentur irgendwann
agentur ripplinger tat
aber ich würde gerne auch mit rein
ich nehme dann einen nachnamen von euch
an ich finde agentur ripplinger pakistan
hat sich komisch an
ja
[Musik]
besten mit der torten säge da geht es
echt ganz gut
[Musik]
jetzt eine halbe stunde später ungefähr
ist der kleister angezogen
und jetzt nehmt ihr hier die butter die
könnt ihr auch ein paar minuten schön
verrühren die ist nämlich weich und dann
gebe ich die buttercreme also die creme
die angerührte creme einfach zur butter
dazu und schlag alles schön geschmeidig
ich geb dir jetzt auch sonst nichts mehr
dazu denn die schmeckt schon nach
vanille
[Musik]
fertig
perfekt ich fühle jetzt kurz hier rein
holt die tortenböden und mein werkzeug
und dann geht es schon mit dem film der
pate los
[Musik]
los geht's mit dem torte füllen also der
erste boden kommt da drauf ich habe
jetzt hier einfach so ein garching bord
und eine tortenplatte ich glaube
tatsächlich dass zuviel buttercremetorte
aber macht nichts
wer möchte kann jetzt auch noch früchte
dazu geben und das ganze fruchtig
gestalten ihr könnt auch eine
schokotorte machen indem ihr einfach nur
ein bisschen cacau zum teig gibt und
etwas kakao oder flüssige schokolade in
die buttercreme und jetzt einmal schön
auffüllen
erstmal mit den großen böden starten
und wenn ihr nicht so geübt seitdem
torte stapel nehmt ihr euch jetzt ein
tortenring drumherum damit alles gerade
wird
[Musik]
noch eins und eins nämlich sogar ist ein
schönes hat sie halt high heels an
[Musik]
die puppe immer mal dazu halten aber das
passt ich tauche sich einig schneide das
noch zu das wird dann kann das jetzt
kurz in die kühlung ich mach jetzt schön
sauber und dann bekommt also erst mal
eine schöne frisur
eine schöne flechtfrisur spielen wir
kurz barbies friseur
[Musik]
jetzt spüre friseur
rosenwasser das lässt deine haare
glänzen
ja und leichter durchkämmen
außerdem wenn du schuppen hast dann
beugt sich bereits vor
und es ist bunt highland
entzündungshemmend und reduziert seine
falten also ein paar stunden
ein bisschen spaß da war das klima gut
weg
so marcel ist so gerne aber
auch tipps zur auswahl
zumal sie so nach sowie im elsass ok
einmal um den kopf
anna
mit käsekuchen backen
[Musik]
ja
okay
[Musik]
für mein video
schön gar eine opencms zur das tun ja
kann schon ein stückchen probe machen
und klar große risiko bitte winterlich
zum frohsinn käsekuchen mit
bier sie mit baiser staub und glitzer
und
in der mitte moment gott eigentlich
müsste nach eis bonbons schmecken
frozen
also wenn ihr wollt dass sarah nicht
mein anna und ich also anna und elsa
einen frozen käsekuchen backen dann
schreibt gerne in die kommentare
ihr müsst nur noch vielleicht dazu
schreiben ob mit verkleidung oder ohne
oder
auch so richtig dieser disney
was gefällt dir die friseur die frisur
ist gut aber dauert das noch lange schön
com analysiert dich auch
für unser video
die klamotte nehmen sie zurückgeschickt
[Gelächter]
wir haben sie natürlich noch
die hängen kleiderschrank
[Musik]
das kleid wird jetzt zugeschnitten ich
habe jetzt schon mal die puppe in eine
folie eingepackt also die beine
zumindest und jetzt kann ich hier mit
einem messer das eigentlich muss ich gar
nicht viel schneiden sondern muss er mit
der creme auffüllen das mache ich jetzt
erstmal einfach mit der creme auffüllen
dann habe ich dann noch ein paar
kuchenstücke übrig das heißt die kann
ich auch benutzen dann zu schneiden und
dann wird es jetzt eine schöne runde
form
[Musik]
ja zu einer tankkarte kriegt er das dann
immer recht schön und schnell glatt
und es geht so echt schnell wenn man
diese zehn und zwölf zentimeter ringe
nimmt oder wenn ihr ebene platte packt
und es so rund aus schlecht das geht
auch gut dann hat man nämlich schon
diese schöne kleid vor
jetzt oben auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen ausbessern
[Musik]
und jetzt hier oben ausstechen damit die
barbie die er sah david die elsa hier
auch platz hat ich nehme jetzt einfach
so ein apfel entkernt
und kann das ganz schön rausnehmen
[Musik]
einmal kurz die arme augen
und drumherum muss ich das jetzt noch
ausbessern damit es wirklich aussieht
als wäre das kleid schön geschmeidig so
eine schöne art hoffe ein abschnitt
[Musik]
schön
ich würde sagen teil eins ist erledigt
dieses kleid gefällt mir sehr gut ich
stelle die elsa jetzt in den kühlschrank
da darf sie einmal komplett erkalten und
die glasur darum kümmere ich mich dann
morgen ja sie können jetzt erst mal über
nacht kühl stehen und so könnt ihr euch
das auch zeit nicht ganz gut aufteilen
damit das ganze nicht so lange dauert
aber ich muss sagen bisher ging es auch
recht schnell nur habe ich jetzt keine
zeit
jetzt bekommt die puppe also die elsa
puppe ihr kleid und zwar wird es jetzt
die bono tsunami klausur das ist nicolas
uhr die pudding ähnlich ist und dann
später schon über das kleist über das
kleid jesus jetzt bekam die elsa puppe
ihr gewand das wird die produktion eine
creme die ich schon mal gemacht habe in
heller version mit weißer schokolade und
diese creme ist so eine art pudding und
die fließt dann später schönes kleid
drüber für die füllung verwende ich 100
gramm sahne 125 gramm milch 8 gramm
stärke das ist ein esslöffel 100 gramm
weiße schokolade 100 gramm kondensmilch
dass die gezuckerte 100 gramm saure
sahne vanille extrakt und eventuell
brauche ich dann nochmal 50 gramm sahne
zuerst einmal verriet er jetzt die sahne
in einem topf mit der stärke
schön klümpchen frei
[Musik]
da kommt noch die milch dazu und dann
könnt ihr das ganze kurz aufkochen
lassen
[Musik]
und dann gebt ihr hier jetzt die
schokolade rein
schön einrühren bis sie geschmolzen ist
solange mein sellerie aufwerten
das mache ich immer zwischendrin das
seht ihr im juni
sondern die person hinter der kamera
herr zimmer heute
wenn die schokolade aufgelöst ist kommt
die kondensmilch dazu
und dann auch die saure sahne und das
vanille extrakt und dann kurz die
zutaten schön einrühren
zufällig die klasse um damit sie
schneller abkühlen kann im kupfer topf
da wird jetzt nämlich noch lange lange
warm bleiben der hält die hitze so gut
wie kreisen sogar noch besser
das wollen wir jetzt nicht soll es schon
abkühlen aber ich kann jetzt hier auch
schon mal die verpasste dazu geben denn
elsa bekommt natürlich ein blaues kleid
deswegen verpasste in blau dazu
verrühren und dann kurz im kühlschrank
stellen
[Musik]
bist du bereit für die elsa torte
jetzt müssen wir noch kurz eine schöne
11 haustier machen ein alter zopf
nicht die haare firmen nur flächen
keine gute idee
schönere
[Musik]
bequem
jetzt kurz stimmt
und ich hab
das nicht so hoch
[Musik]
ich habe eine elser puppe auch schon
frisiert
[Musik]
also wer hat die haare flechten kam der
kann vielleicht ist nämlich immer man
macht immer so eine rundum drehung
[Musik]
was sagt papa heute morgen gemacht
hat die haare geschnitten weil du
marshmallows drin hattest ja
freuen räubertochter
[Musik]
ihre schöne else können wir machen die
torte fertig
meine süße elser aus bist du bereit für
die torte
kann man wir setzen die jetzt mal auf
diesen teller am besten ein teller mit
rand denn später wird bestimmt was
auslaufen
[Musik]
wow unser hat sich bewegt
das stimmt okay da ist die elsa hier ist
die glasur von der konsistenz hält ich
hab mir die haben ja und wer hier dieses
schöne blau- und wisst ihr was wir jetzt
noch machen ich habe diese metallic
kuchen glasur die mischt man eigentlich
mit wasser an und hat einfach so eine
schöne glanz klausur aber man kann dir
auch hier mit rein geben damit auch
jetzt schon die glasur hier schimmert
wie sich hier schon glitzer partikel
in der luft
die geben wir hier mit rein da hatte
auch einen schönen glanz
ja
das kann ich und es wird die kamera so
gut rüberkommt aber die glitzert echt
heftig das ist schön buch mein gesicht
wird auch gleich
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier ein ringen außenraum
den habe ich jetzt hier mit orten rand
folie gemacht und zwar hält er jetzt
gleich die glasur hoffe ich
ihr könnt auch so ein mini burger ring
nehmen aber dann sieht man halt von der
elsa nichts mehr deswegen dachte ich
nehme mir jetzt das
okay sind wir kurz gucken ob alles dicht
ist
streiche nochmal drüber
vermutlich sehen
die ich ausgewählt habe diese müsste
schönes
ok
tricks einfach aber minimal rein
hier kommt jetzt siegler so rein und das
ist eigentlich so dieser
überraschungseffekt dass dann praktisch
das geburtstagskind
airlines zum beispiel mit honig so als
hättest du geburtstag hast
[Gelächter]
du keine elster krone auf nein endlich
weg ach da ist ja schon meine quatsch
los komm her ich mach dir das mal
post ikone aber schnell griffbereit
jetzt bist du das geburtstagskind und
dann kommt nämlich die glasur ich hier
rein und wird dann praktisch am tisch
der ringe mehr weggezogen und dann wird
elsass kleid wunderschön ok also ein
walt disney magic moment
kriegen wir hin oder also
ich muss jetzt halt irgendwie die
perfekte menge herausfinden
und ich mache mir noch ein bisschen
auf die andere seite
ganz loslassen die haare brauchst nicht
halten immer nicht halten
ich denke es sollte reichen oder
zum überziehen
jetzt hat es mal
[Musik]
wenn ich nur sparen zauber saga eclipse
drauf ich hab so ein bisschen
lebensmittel blitzer
dankeschön aus
[Musik]
der moment der wahrheit bist du
aufgeregt hoffst du dass es klappt ich
hoffe wir haben jetzt nicht so viel
creme und nicht so wenig mag ja soll ich
machen
macht nichts zu gast haben mit elsa
warnen und wenn gott wie schön ist es
geworden
wie wunderschön was ich mache hier noch
ein bisschen bis hin klausur drauf das
ist der hammer
[Musik]
ist
der hammer ich glaube wir machen jetzt
kurz fotos sondern probleme die gleiche
oder
ist unser
ist auch weiße schokolade ich glaube
unser versuch ist geglückt oder
doch schon die macht
[Musik]
jetzt sieht man endlich das eine torte
isst gern wir probieren jetzt mal
ich dachte sie sich auf die nase das
buttercreme
schmeckt's nicht
aber die creme da die glasur das ist
schokolade
und wie schmeckt
was sagst dass du die torte
ach so für mich
dankeschön ich krieg auch nochmal creme
habe die ist echt gut das ist halt eine
echt leckere schokoladencreme wie so
eine art pudding
jetzt sag mal wie findest du die torte
sich die cool geworden oder nicht so
cool
bei meinen kindern ist einfach der punkt
vorbei das andere kind würde es
wahrscheinlich ausflippen wenn so eine
torte bekäme meine kinder kriegen zu oft
solche torten glaube ich tue
das ist die begeisterung die ich haben
wollte
der schauspieler
also dann gehen wir jetzt kuchenessen
die wir teilen den schon mit allen oder
ja ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen probiert gerne aus falls ihr
keine echte puppe in die torte stecken
wollt könnt ihr auch ein bild ausdrucken
ein laminieren und das ganze als
aufsteller reinstecken das geht auch
natürlich
mit puppe finde ich schon auch cool weil
man kann ja auch sodann dem
geburtstagskind oder zu welchem anlass
auch immer kam er dann auch schön die
puppe als geburtstagsgeschenk
verschenken das war sogar noch die von
samira damals aber die hatte der ella
weitervererbt deswegen hatten wird ihnen
auch gab also viel spaß beim nachmachen
schreibt mir gerne welche walt disney
torte ich als nächstes machen soll
vielleicht habt ihr auch eine einen
lieblingsfilm welches ist dein lieblings
luca und
ok schreibt mir gerne euren lieblings
film und welche walt disney oder welche
andere dort auch immer ich packen soll
dann mache ich das ganz gerne bis zum
nächsten mal
und diana und esser torte als mit der
käsekuchen mit sarah da kommt auch noch
ich glaube wir brauchen noch mal kostüme
oder ich glaube dass man schon im
christina untersagt mit musical
mit ganze musikvideo
zur nächsten mal herrscht ob so viel
creme zu essen wir haben mit allen
müssen noch einen elfer
lizenz erst meinen kühlschrank erstmal
gibt es mittagessen
[Musik]